it's day seven I've been at the house
for a week I've been here for hours I
don't even think I've been here you've
been here maybe two days
that's our friend Andy who didn't make
the cut for being in this vlog but did
make the cut for drinking heavily in the
background yeah create a counter vlog
why I was gonna do that but I don't know
how to use this equipment and you guys
don't this equipment is iMovie it's
hitting a button it says record the
train station so you know it's the least
you could do
yeah you left me an orange train station
alone for more than six minutes gonna
get mugged I'm tall awkward and fairly
unattractive and not able to defend
myself those are probably a good
majority of the qualities that they look
for when they're looking for someone
spray-on seat if they're just a guy that
wants to steal your awesome iPod grace
listens to crap bass isn't into music so
much grace doesn't like buzzes you know
what I'm so emotional over it sickening
because you're doing us Catholics have
been taught to repress any emotion
Frazee how was your walk to the train
station I was walking and there was a
little Spanish family in front of me and
they saw me coming behind them and that
I was doing the New York walk fast thing
like I'm on my way to the train to New
York and I'm walking quickly and you're
and they got out of my way I recognized
that you weren't part of a family have
Busboys and dishwashers and they
respected that hey I take offense to
that as a Hispanic woman I take offense
to it as a former Olive Garden employee
didn't you all leave there without
telling them you are coming back and
disrespect every breath never in high
school when it was cool to sit in the
back of the bus yeah we bring a boom box
and this is before iPods and we'd always
make a mix CD and I recently found these
mixed CDs and there were songs on there
that I'm sure I was dancing and singing
to and I can't even believe that I was
doing that in front of people I just
clicked the first track and it was like
face down ass up that's the way we like
to [ __ ] fit you know that song thanks
Pam yeah I never even had sex in high
school so I don't know that all I was
talking about